well hello there you must be Ron Swanson
welcome to Casa Ludgate hello Mr ludge
ah call me Larry
it's zuzu's boss oh Ron Rita Ludgate oh
you have no idea how nice it is to meet
you
oh come in for God's sake what can I get
you to drink oh could you take your
shoes off please thank you so much
uh nothing to drink thanks oh okay is
April around uh Zuzu you have a guest
I'll bet you
I'll come with you okay uh you make
yourself at home Mr Swanson thank you
you must be April's sister
I'm Ron
nice to meet you
Natalie hey it's me Andy You're an hour
and a half late I know I know I had to
massage a ton of feet super sorry come
on get in I I need to do everything on
April's list so she's not gonna go out
with me
you're into April come on well we'll
talk about in the car hold on I'll get
my books okay
are you trying to lure this young lady
into your van
but she's being really difficult about
it
uh and it's actually not my van I stole
it from a friend of mine I technically
shouldn't be even driving because uh
my license is crazy expired that's uh
Dwyer
d-w-y-e-r dude come on I gotta get out
of here Natalie tell this guy you know
me
[Music]
by the power vested in Me by the state
of Indiana I Now pronounce you husband
and wife
don't fly away
okay all right so that one is dead we
know that my sister is lame but Andy's
sort of cool I guess I kind of see why
he'd marry her also if anyone finds my
gray hoodie I lost it thanks
that was beautiful okay I'm ready good
wait
not ready super scared Andy you said you
wanted to be an action star this is your
chance okay
okay you Natalie follow the action
whatever what do I have to do hold up
this butter knife to my throat and
pretend like you're holding me hostage
ready
I don't know it seems a little crazy
just crazy enough to work
oh my face my face is fine Mikhail
Petrov forget it Macklin you're too late
I'm sorry guys I I need my cheaters I
cannot say anything you're doing really
good you're doing really good really
yeah help me Agent Macklin help me he's
stolen my jewels and now he's gonna
ravish my body and he stinks he really
stinks okay Janet snakehold belongs to
Mother Russia now oh that's what you
think and I hope you like pain
looks like this Siberian Husky is going
to be rushing
off to jail
can I go Gail is making a roast
oh